قال الجيش الاسرائيلي ان 45 جنديا في من
صفوفه اصيبوا فيما سماها حوادث عمليات منذ
بدايه المعارك البريه في ال 27 من اكتوبر
ومن بين هؤلاء 27 اصيبوا بجروح خطيره
للغايه كما اعلن ان
388 جنديا اصيبوا بسبب سوء استخدام
الاسلحه والمتفجرات في حين اصيب
54 بما وصفه بنيران صديقه واصيب 21 اخرون
في اطلاق نار غير مبرر وجرح 31 جنديا في
حوادث سير وكانت اخر احصائيه نشرت قبل شهر
تحدثت عن مقتل 38 جنديا اسرائيليا في
حوادث وقعت منذ بدايه المعارك
البريه معنا من غلاف غزه مراسل الجزيره
الياس كرام الياس كيف بدات بيانات جيش
الاحتلال الصبا ضحيه خاصه مع انطلاق
صفارات الانذار ايضا في المنطقه المنطقه
المحاذيه
للغلاف سلمى الجيش الاسرائيلي مازال يتحدث
عن ما يسميها الانجازات في قطاع غزه سواء
كان ذلك في المناطق الشماليه او الوسطى او
الجنوبيه ويشير في بياناته اليوميه الى ان
الجيش الاسرائيلي ما زال يحرز تقدما على
صعيد الوصول الى مخازن الاسلحه و منصات
اطلاق الصواريخ وتضيق الخناق ايضا على
القياده قياده المقاومه الفلسطينيه سواء
العسكريه او السياسيه في منطقه خان يونس
رغم ان اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي تحدثت هذا
اليوم نقلا عن مصادر عسكريه قالت بان
الجيش الاسرائيلي يبدو بعيد المنال عن
الوصول الى كافه المنصات الصاروخيه التي
تطلق منها الصواريخ باتجاه اسرائيل وان
الجيش الاسرائيلي ربما سيحتاج الى عام او
عامين للوصول الى كل المنصات التي تطلق
منها الصواريخ باتجاه اسرائيل على اعتبار
ان المقاومه الفلسطينيه خباتها وحصنها في
اماكن تحت الارض من الصعب على الجيش
الاسرائيلي الوصول اليها وهذا يتقاطع ايضا
مع تقاريره اجنبيه كانت تحدثت في هذا
السياق ايضا على ان الجيش الاسرائيلي ربما
لم يتمكن من القضاء سوى على ثلث قدره
المقاومه ال الفلسطينيه العسكريه وتقاطع
ايضا مع تقارير اجنبيه يبدو انها جاءت من
مصادر اسرائيليه بطبيعه الحال كانت تتحدث
عن ان الجيش الاسرائيلي ربما وصل الى 20%
او 30% من الانفاق الهجوميه ودمرها
وبالتالي امام هذا العجز
وال التراجع في قدره الجيش الاسرائيلي في
تحقيق اهداف هذه الحرب نحن نرى ايضا في
المقابل بان الاسرائيليين الذين يقتلون
هنا في المناطق القريبه من غلاف غزه يت
يترددون من العوده الى بلداتهم القريبه من
السياج الامني ويرفضون ذلك وكان هنالك
اجتماع صاخب مع المسؤولين في الحكومه
الاسرائيليه في الايام الاخيره حيث رفض
رؤساء السلطات المحليه في بلدات غلاف غزه
العوده الى بلداتهم على ضوء هذا الوضع
الامني وطلبوا من الحكومه تمديد فتره
بقائهم في الفنادق والمنتجعات حتى الاول
من تموز يوليو المقبل وهذا يشير الى
انعدام الثقه حقيقه سلمى ما بين
رؤساء السلطات المحليه في منطقه غلاف غزه
وما بين الحكومه الاسرائيليه التي تحاول
حثهم على العوده والسكن في هذه البلدات
لكن واضح بان هنالك مخاوف من جانب
الاسرائيليين بالعوده الى بلداتهم على ضوء
ما يرونه ايضا من معارك تتجدد بين الحين
والاخر في المناطق الشماليه لقطاع غزه
وتحديدا في مناطق قريبه جدا من السياج
الامني قبل قليل كانت الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه قد اغارت على مناطق في وسط
مدينه غزه ونحن نرى ايضا سحب الدخان التي
تنبعث من المناطق الجنوبيه للمدينه فيما
نشير الى ان المعارك ما زالت مستمره سلمى
حقيقه ونحن نسمع بين الحين والاخر ايضا
الاسلحه الرشاشه الثقيله التي تستخدم في
اطار هذه المعارك شكرا لك مراسلنا من غلاف
غزه الياس كرام